The downfall of the Big Three had a major impact on the Rochester community.
The loss of income and benefits created a ripple effect,
straining local schools, hospitals, and social services that had long relied on corporate sponsorship.
As employment opportunities dried up, the city's population began to decline.
Young adults, once attracted to the stability and opportunity offered by Rochester's major
employers, began to leave in search of work elsewhere.
Loss of talent became a serious concern, particularly as newly graduated engineers,
designers, and business minds from local institutions like the University of Rochester,
U of R, and Rochester Institute of Technology, RIT, found few reasons to stay.
Entire neighborhoods, particularly those near-old factories and offices, began to decline.
Commercial districts that had once thrived with foot traffic were now filled with empty stores
and boarded up buildings. Downtown Rochester, once vibrant with bustling crowds,
grew quiet. This visible decline left a lasting impact on the community's morale and identity.
Perhaps most significantly, Rochester's identity as a company town began to crumble.